[Music]
a filter bubble is your own personal
universe of information that's been
generated by algorithms that are trying
to guess what you're interested in and
increasingly online we live in these
bubbles they follow us around they form
part of the fabric of most web sites
that we visit and I think we're starting
to see how they're creating some
challenges for democracy you know we've
always chosen media that conforms to our
address and read newspapers or magazines
that in some way reflect what we're
interested in who we want to be but the
age of kind of algorithmically mediated
media is really different in a couple of
ways so one way is it's not something
that we know that we're choosing so we
don't know on what basis who an
algorithm things we are and therefore we
don't know how it's deciding what to
show us or not show us and it's often
that not showing us part that's the most
important we don't know what piece of
the picture we're missing because by
definition it's out of view and so you
know that's increasingly I think part of
what we're seeing online is that it's
getting harder and harder even to
imagine how someone else might come to
the views that they have might see the
world as a way that did they do because
that information is literally not part
of what we're seeing or consuming
another feature of kind of the filter
bubble landscape is that you know it's
automatic and it's not something that
we're choosing we're not when you pick
up a left-wing magazine or a right-wing
magazine we know what the bias is what
to expect a deeper problem with
algorithms choosing what we see and what
we don't see is that the data that they
have to base those decisions on is
really not representative of the whole
of who we are as human beings so
Facebook is basically trying to take a
handful of sort of decisions about what
to click on and what not to click on
maybe how much time we spend with
different things and trying to extract
from that some general truth about
what we're interested in or what we care
about and that clicking self who in you
know fractions of a second is trying to
decide am i interested in this article
am I not it just isn't a very full
representation of the whole of our human
self you can you can do this experiment
where you can look back at you know your
web history for the last month and
obviously you know there gonna be some
some things there that really gave you a
lot of value that represent you know
your your true self or your innermost
self but there's a lot of stuff you know
I I click on cell phone reviews even
though I'll always have an iPhone I
never I'm not gonna have an iPhone but
it's just some kind of compulsion that I
have and and I don't particularly need
or want algorithms amping up my desire
to read useless technology reviews so
the people who create these algorithms
like to say like they're neutral we
don't want to create a kind of take an
editorial point of view and I think
there's you know there's something to
that that's important you know we don't
want Mark Zuckerberg to impose his
political views on all of us and I don't
think he is but it's also kind of a
weird dodge because every time that you
create a list and that's essentially all
that Facebook or Twitter as is a list
with the ranks information every time
you create a list you're making some
value judgments about what goes at the
top of the list and the bottom of the
list there is no such thing as a neutral
algorithm and you have to decide on some
basis that some things are going to be
more valuable more worthy of attention
than others I always find a dangerous
when people say you know there's no
editorial viewpoint here we're not
taking an editorial stand because every
every list has some kind of viewpoint
about what matters and what doesn't
matter there's no such thing as a
neutral list because if I'm neutral on
one criterion often I'll be biased on
some other criterion so if I rank people
by alphabetically there's no guarantee
that that's going to have an equal
impact on people of different
Felicity's or different races or
different genders what we have to
grapple with is we do have these kind of
much more powerful than ever before
editors shaping what we see in don't see
but they themselves haven't really taken
on the responsibility of that editorial
judgment
[Music]